Today, we're going to be speaking with James
Fletcher, who is the producer and director
of the documentary film The Accidental President.
I appear in this film.
I've played the trailer for my audience on
on the live stream that that I've done recently.
And I appear very early in the trailer, which
I really appreciate.
James, it's so it's so great to have you on.
OK, so the accidental president, I think we
can sort of infer the idea that Donald Trump
wanted to run for president, not necessarily
to to be president.
Talk to us about the premise there.
Well, I mean, it's it's like the plot of a
ridiculous Hollywood movie that got out of
control.
I mean, I can attest this was an attention
seeking exercise that went crazy.
And Donald Trump was looking for a bit of
attention.
And suddenly, by breaking all the rules, if
you like, of campaign law, he became the front
runner in the Republican field and the thing
ran away.
And we all know what happened.
So the title alludes to the fact that this
was nothing more than a bit of fun he was
having and suddenly it took on a whole life
of its own.
In the film, you interview all sorts of folks
from sort of more pragmatic, traditional Republicans
all the way to what I guess I would call more
cultish true believers like Scott Adams of
Dilbert fame.
Can you talk a little bit about what were
the trends you saw in terms of their perspective
on this presidency of Trump's comparing the
more traditional Republicans who have been
involved in the party for for some time versus
these kind of new entrants who who are really
Trump fans more than they are anything else?
Well, of course, you know, the Trump won one
title replied with for the film was was the
hostile takeover.
But I thought Trump would have liked that
too much.
But he, in fact, did the same to the Republican
Party.
And as you say, the Republican establishment
were shocked and completely unprepared for
his arrival.
They didn't know how to deal with it or confront
him as a candidate.
And, of course, they treated him for the most
part as a joke.
So in finding our interviewees, we wanted
to look at people from all corners of the
establishment.
We spoke to Matt Schlapp, the chairman of
CPAC, who I don't think was a Trump one's
really honest about it.
But then we went, as you say, to people like
Scott, Saddam's time wasn't really pro Trump
as he is now, because we wanted to illustrate
that inside the Republican Party, there were
two very different factions, you know, people
who believe in the GOP and people who believe
in Trump.
Do you know who?
So there's all these stories of even up to
Election Day, Trump still didn't think he
was going to win and was shocked when when
he won.
And and in contrast to that, there was the
Republican primary process in 2016, which
started with 17.
And as it started to get whittled down, Trump
ended up sort of accruing the support from
all of these people whose one, two, three
percent support ended up having to find a
new place to go.
Who figured out that Trump could win more
quickly the people immediately around Trump
or the Republican establishment that was watching
this?
That's a really good question.
I honestly don't know the answer.
But what was explained to me was if you, for
example, hated or you loved Ted Cruz, but
you hated, I don't know, Marco Rubio, you
thought, well, I'll put I'll put the votes
on Trump because he's going to he's not going
to do well anyway.
He'll probably drop out.
I said that.
Sorry.
That's a terrible example because they were
some of the last people standing.
If you take if you take Rand Paul, for example,
there's one percent's right.
You would transfer your one percent to Trump
because that was before Christmas and people
thought this is all a bit of fun, but it would
be it would be over fairly soon.
And so Trump was blessed by this mathematical
advantage of having 16 opponents.
And as these as these people fell out one
by one, almost for a bit of entertainment,
if I think a lot of people are really honest
with themselves, they put the money on Trump
because he was such compelling viewing, so
entertaining in a field of Republicans, whether
the other 16 basically blurred into one and
I think had to take the entertainment value
as Trump is not to be underestimated in any
way.
That's interesting.
So some of that Trump support that shifted
earlier from the ones and twos, as we were
calling them at the time, were people who
were sort of thinking, eventually I will settle
on whoever is the nominee and it probably
will be somebody other than Trump.
That's right.
And this is a bit of entertainment along the
way.
And we'll see where the cards land and then
we'll decide if we're going to be serious
about it.
But, of course, you know, as is often the
case in politics, you need to put your stake
in the ground earlier, earlier in the process
rather than later.
Do you did you get any kind of sense of when
and how the Republican establishment, when
it became clear that it was going to be Trump
as the nominee, not as the eventual president,
but as the nominee if how did they or did
they sort of race into action to try to get
control of the candidacy?
Well, that's right.
And Matt Schlapp talks about this in the film.
I mean, that panic happened again, too late.
A lot of people treated Trump as a bit of
a sideshow.
And so they didn't tackle him in the way he
would have been tackled, in my opinion, if
he were treated as a serious candidate from
day one.
And a lot of people thought the damage he
could do to, for example, if I'm you know,
if I'm against Marco Rubio, it doesn't help
hurt me to think he's going to insult Marco
Rubio or Jeb Bush with the nicknames and run
them down.
So he's actually doing me a favor.
And as long as he's in in the field, he's
probably good for me.
But what a lot of people overlooked was the
fact that, as Molly Ball puts it, he would
run through the Republican field like a buzzsaw.
And it was too late by the time people in
the Republican establishment realized this
had happened.
And it was, frankly, very little they could
do about it.
And certainly by the time he reached twelve
thirty seven, which people forget happened
before the convention.
So he goes to the Republican convention as
the presumed nominee.
Right, and one of the things that we've talked
about in terms of that process is that if
Donald Trump had run, as in the Democratic
primary, he never would have stood a shot.
There are fundamental differences between
the Democratic primary electorate and the
Republican primary electorate, which even
if accounting for this idea of I wanted Rand
and he's out, I'll say Trump, but eventually
I'll go with whoever it is.
Jeb, even if you account for that, Trump would
have never gone anywhere in the Democratic
primary.
Did any of the people you spoke to in some
way comment on or understand that this was
only possible because of who Republican primary
voters are?
I think that's right.
And, you know, it's also worth mentioning
that at the convention, there was an attempt
to destabilize the Trump candidacy.
And Paul Manafort got a lot of credit for
spotting those threats and seeing them off.
But, yes, I mean, fundamentally, the difference
between the two parties was magnified and
made very clear, by the way, Trump was able
to march through that field effectively unchallenged
at this point.
Is there any sort of you can't argue with
success type of perspective because of what
Donald Trump was able to do?
Or does the fact that he was made only the
tenth one term president and this is this
is post filming of the documentary, but it's
sort of more of a now question.
Does the fact that he was made a one term
president in some way vindicate the people
who early on were not Trump people?
It's really interesting thought.
But I mean, I would say one of the covid killed
Trump.
I mean, I don't know where you stand on that,
but I think I agree.
I think without covid, he probably would have
sailed through reelection.
But nevertheless, for four years, his business
card, the president of the United States,
and he won.
And you know, and as painful as that is for
a lot of people, you know, our film is looking
at how he won and how basically a game show
host became the most powerful person on the
planet because it happened.
And admittedly, it was a perfect storm of
all kinds of luck, bizarre circumstances,
as you say, the Republican establishment.
And that rules.
But but he won and nearly won twice.
And so I can attest there is a very solid
basis on which to launch an inquiry in this
case, a documentary called The Accidental
President.
What do you think is the desire of the more
traditional Republican Party insiders?
That would be the future of the Republican
Party, because now there's this question with
people like Madison, Kathyrn and Lauren Bobert
and Marjorie Taylor Green, who really are
only in Congress because they were on Trump's
side and they were simpatico to Trump.
We don't know whether they will be reelected
or not in twenty, twenty two.
And there's a real question as to whether
the Republican Party will remain a Trump party
or go back to what it was before the more
traditional insider types that you interviewed
in the film.
What do you think they want now?
Well, I think it's I think 20 22 will be really
interesting if if the Republicans come storming
back and Trump in some way as this de facto
leader of the opposition, I know that's not
enough.
It's obviously in American politics.
But he's put himself there if they do very
well in twenty twenty two and his people and
he can take the credit for it with the get
whatever credibility that I think Trump stays.
And it'll be very difficult to dismiss him.
However, if it's a wipeout in twenty, twenty
two, I think people in the Republican establishment
would say Trump is now a massive liability
and we've got to find a way of getting rid
of him presence.
I wonder if that you know, at the CPAC speech,
there was the rumor Trump might announce for
2024 and then, of course, he didn't.
But he did announce, you know, you can donate
money on his website and he's going to be
supporting candidates in 2022.
It almost seems like a trial balloon where
if he can continue to sort of play kingmaker
and wield influence successfully in 2022,
maybe it makes his 2004 run more likely.
And if it doesn't work, then he can not necessarily
gracefully exit, but at least exit.
That's right.
And of course, David, you know, if he were
to run in 2020 for one, for, as he put it
a third time, I'm sure you'd have no contest
at that point.
Yeah, but yeah, I think I do think 2022 will
be the moment at which the Republican Party
will either decide we've got to hang onto
him even if we can't stand the thought, because
he does win for us.
And this is all you know, this is not my opinion.
But if if it's a wipeout, then I think I mean,
the problem is there isn't an obvious candidate,
which you would think by now that might be
so 2022.
I think he's going to be a pivotal moment
for the Republican establishment.
How much does all of this, number one, depend
on and will be guided by what's going on in
other parts of the world?
Because at the time of Trump, we also had
the rise of some of these nationalist right
wing parties in different parts of Europe,
the Boris Johnson ization.
In England and in all of these different things,
and that that also may change over the next
two to four years, does it is Trump big enough
now that it doesn't matter anymore?
Or is there still some kind of global picture
here that will dictate?
I don't know if I can correct me if you disagree,
but I'm not sure that what's happening outside
of America particularly informs what happens
inside America.
I mean, the Brexit vote for me was an indication
that this that Trump could happen.
Right.
But I don't think it's possible to say that
Trump happened because of Brexit or that it
paved the way.
I think the conditions in America were amenable
to Trump win, which wasn't as obvious at the
time as it was in retrospect.
So I'm not sure global politics will have
much bearing.
Yeah, I'm not inclined to at least not to
disagree strongly in terms of the production
of the film.
And we're talking with James Fletcher about
the documentary The Accidental President.
You produced it over quite a period of time.
What is the how do you even manage logistically?
You have all of these interviews.
You have the big picture story you want to
tell.
I'm trying to figure out what how how are
you organized the day to day to end up putting
the story you want to tell together from all
the footage that you have?
What happened was we finished our last interview
with Kellyanne Conway the very day Trump announced
locked down in the United States.
So that was, I think, early March of last
year.
Yeah.
And we started editing literally a week before
lockdown.
I just appointed the editor.
And so I never spent any time in the same
room as him, which is extraordinary and unheard
of when working on any film.
And the same is true of everyone else in post-production.
The composer was in Los Angeles.
The sound design was done in London.
The color was of the pitch.
It was done in Texas by a guy from New York
who was in lockdown with his wife's family.
So it was a real challenge.
And all the meetings that you would normally
have in person and trial and error and creative
ideas weren't possible in the normal way.
But we got there.
And but we I think what you're asking is we
shot the film from June 15 until Election
Day of 2016.
So in a way, it didn't really matter.
The only thing I was personally disappointed
was that we had to release the film later
than I would like to.
But it's a balanced piece anyway.
I don't think it would have made any difference
to the outcome of the election had we released
that, for example, in September, as people
in CA just encouraged us to.
I think if I wanted to affect the election,
I'd have had to basically to hit job on Trump.
And that's not what this film is.
When you're sitting there and you're putting
it together.
And as people will see when they watch that,
there will be I'll say something and then
it'll cut to somebody else and then a third
person.
Are you working off of transcripts to say,
we want this line and then this line?
Are you going from memory from the interviews,
which seems like it would be so difficult
to do?
It was a bit of both.
I mean, I, I did all the transcripts myself,
so in my head I had all the lines I liked.
And then I went through the transcripts with
literally pen and paper.
And I put lines on the for example, all the
things I wanted to put in the film that you
said that of course, you were into the fact
that it's just under a hundred and twenty
minutes, one hundred and ten minute film.
And so sadly, when you've got twenty, almost
one hour interviews, a lot of things don't
make it into the final cut, which is really
frustrating.
And then, you know, people have asked this
is should this have been a 10 part limited
series?
I'm not sure people that have the stomach
for that show.
I would have had to stomach to make it and
watch as much trouble as I did.
But we didn't have a plan.
And everyone approaches documentary making
a different way.
But I think between me and Noah, the editor,
it was really the two of us who did this whole
thing.
I don't see massive credit to him.
Yeah, we we just pull it on knows we we probably
would not get a film school for the way we
did it, but I just felt it had to feel very
natural and keep moving.
And so we were brutal in that if someone was
waffling or going on too long and the sentence
was cut in half.
Right.
That's how most of my footage ended up being
cut.
In fact, because of the waffling.
No, possible no, no.
It's a it's an excellent documentary.
We're talking with James Fletcher, the producer
and director of The Accidental President.
And where are the easiest places for people
to find the film?
So it's on Apple TV in 72 countries.
We've translated the subtitles into Latin
American Spanish.
It's also on Amazon and Google Play.
The whole Android platform is covered as well.
And YouTube.
James, thank you so much for talking to us
about it.
Thank you very much,